the new illuminarium las vegas immerses
you inside our planet and beyond but for
earth day on friday rocky is taking us
into the wild
i have escaped to africa and i'm living
my dream on an african safari but i
didn't have to go far from home calum
that's right it's hard to believe we're
not in kenya right now
but we aren't we're here in illuminarium
at area 15 enjoying some time with just
the most magnificent creatures of the
african elephants unfortunately another
one of our endangered species and we
really want to celebrate and honor their
majesty right here this is incredible
tell us what we're what we're seeing
right now in this scene so the natural
grazing and natural watering hole for
them we set up a five camera array so we
could film them in their natural habitat
without making them jittery or nervous
that we're they're in the presence uh so
you just get to be in awe at uh what
some of our planet has to offer
absolutely and let's talk about how you
got these images in these videos so we
sent crews out to four different
countries we filmed in kenya and south
africa tanzania and rwanda which
created some of the most amazing shots
you'll hear about later
and then we brought it together with
generative technology so here in the
room you can actually smell where you
are on the planes you actually get to
feel the rumbles through haptics in the
floor and we're also scanning you in the
area with lidar so as you move around
you get to interact with the projection
you're in a completely immersive
floor-to-ceiling venue uh where we take
you on a journey without you having to
fly so many thousands of miles oh my god
this is so beautiful and what i love
most you know we're celebrating earth
day it is on friday and it's not always
just about conserving and and protecting
the earth it's about learning about it
too so when you come in here there are
captions that show up on the screen so
you can learn about the animals and
learn about what's happening in this
habitat we really want people to feel
that they're getting educated about the
dangers of the planet and the beauty of
the planet at the same time we have a
new show coming up that's going to
celebrate space and right now we're also
running a show on georgia o'keeffe's
wonderful work with flowers so we really
want you to celebrate uh our earth and
learn a little more about it as well
well coming up later in the show we're
going to take you to a scene where there
are some endangered animals that you
definitely want to learn about you don't
want to miss it this is something rare
that you you know might not be able to
see in your lifetime so but you can see
it here at the luminarium so stay tuned
we'll be back